[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce mercredi 4 mai la
haute saison se prépare les recrutements
sont en cours pour les jobs d'été quels
sont les secteurs qui recrutent et
comment être accompagné dans sa
recherche des conseils pour trouver et
candidates et aux emplois saisonniers
dans ce journal il a été pendant un
temps fréquenté par le poète alfred de
musset le gué relais de
jouars-pontchartrain ancien relais de
poste s'est refait une beauté un nouvel
espace de coworking a été inauguré ce
mercredi 4 mai à découverte des locaux
dans cette édition et puis les montées
éléments thèses sont appelés à élire
leur nouveau maire le premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle de
mantes-la-jolie aura lieu le 15 mai
prochain le point sur les candidats à la
mairie pour cette deuxième partie focus
sur les listes de gauche
[Musique]
vous voulez si champion des bureaux
seraient deux prises branchez votre
compte en banque et après en cuisine a
été caché à volonté comme vous le
souhaitez il est désormais ouvert du
lundi au vendredi le nouvel espace de
coworking de jouars-pontchartrain est et
inauguré ce mercredi 4 mai au total 500
mètres carrés aménagé dans un bâtiment
du xviiie siècle l'ancien relais de
poste c'est le coeur battant du
coworking c'est l'espace de convivialité
c'est la cuisine où tout le monde va
pouvoir venir évidemment se restaurer on
a pensé convivialité on a pensé des
espaces donc partagé pour la
convivialité pour le travail et aussi
des bureaux fermés parce qu'on se rend
bien compte qu'avec les colloques au
vide que des grands espaces ce n'est pas
forcément ce qui est demandé par tous
avec deux salles de réunion trois
plateaux de travail et huit bureaux
l'objectif de l'espace et de s'adapter à
tous que ce soit des télétravailleurs
c'est vrai qu'étant en télétravail
depuis le début de la pandémie ça permet
voilà un petit peu de sortir de son de
son quotidien et puis d'avoir un certain
confort en termes d'installations c'est
vraiment un très beau bâtiment moi je le
connaissais pas du tout donc vraiment le
choix des matériaux de l'agencement etc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment super ou
même des entrepreneurs à l'image de cet
homme j'ai tout à créer maintenant par
rapport à mon projet professionnel et
notamment faire du réseau
rencontrer des gens et donc
l'orientation écologie qui a été
présentée fera par monsieur le maire ça
forcément ça peut m'intéresser en vue de
construire cette nouvelle partie de ma
carrière penser en 2017 par la commune
il aura fallu patienter cinq ans avant
de donner une nouvelle vie à ce lieu
historique près de la mairie fréquenté
il fut un temps par le poète alfred de
musset nous avons rencontré de l'amiante
du plomb le coc vide des interruptions
de chantier bon en fait tout ce qu'on
peut cumuler comme comme problématique
mais finalement on a tenu bon on ouvre
et puis je pense que le résultat est à
la hauteur un coût total avoisinant les
2,5 millions d'euros pour les futurs
abeilles de la ruche les tarifs ne sont
pas encore définitifs les tout premiers
inscrits ont pu bénéficier d'une offre
spéciale le mois de mai était gratuit
[Musique]
que ce soit hôtes d'accueil ou menuisier
ce parc d'accrobranche situé à saint
germain en laye recherche actuellement
des saisonniers surtout pour la période
estivale les week-ends on recrute tous
types de saisonniers pour faire de
l'accueil client de la pose de la mise
en place de baudriers des interventions
dans les arbres de la gestion du snack
on cherche également des menuisiers pour
faire de la maintenance des élagueurs et
donc tous types de profils de
saisonniers sont extrêmement demandés
recherché il existe deux parcs accroc
campent dans les yvelines ces deux
établissements recherche une dizaine de
personnes pas facile pour lui de trouver
les bons candidats c'est plutôt
difficile à recruter
on met des annonces sur la plupart des
grands sites de recherche d'emploi mais
pour autant ça reste compliqué donc on
est obligé de mettre des annonces à
l'entrée de nos parcs on cherche
également des responsables de snacks on
veut vraiment développer nos snacks et
on a beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans le
domaine de l'alimentaire de la
restauration à trouver des responsables
de se mettre dans cette salle d'escaladé
à montigny le bretonneux l'assistant rh
commence en ce début mais également le
recrutement des emplois saisonniers ont
cherché entre nous deux personnes entre
juin et août qui se plissent pour
restaurant accueille bas c'est entre
juin et juillet c'est plus pour
renforcer et à l'ouverture de la
terrasse avec les beaux jours et en
outils plus pour pallier aux congés des
personnes en poste en cdi pour trouver
la perle rare la société post des
annonces sur le site de l'entreprise ou
sur ce site d'offres d'emploi même
constat que pour l'accrobranche le
domaine de la restauration ne trouvent
pas de candidats pour l'instauration ce
badge poussé oui c'est vraiment beaucoup
plus compliqué on reçoit vraiment pas
beaucoup de ces lions passent par là du
coup vie notre site on a aussi été la
restauration du coup là on fait de plus
en plus appel à brouilla bhl ceux des
extras pour pallier au manque de
personnels qu'on a notamment fini les
restaurateurs peine donc à trouver des
employés même problématique en
hôtellerie même si ce secteur ne
recherche pas forcément des saisonniers
dans les yvelines en période estivale
c'est plutôt le secteur des loisirs qui
recrutent comme les parcs d'attraction
ou l'isi de loisirs
[Musique]
lieu de vie et d'entr'aide le phare
jeunesse à guyancourt accueille les
jeunes de 15 à 25 ans pour les aider
dans leur parcours projet orientation
scolaire ou encore loisirs le but
accompagner les jeunes vers l'autonomie
en ce moment c'est la période des
recrutements pour les jobs d'été les
professionnels de cette structure
accompagne les guyancourt toi dans leur
recherche d'emploi saisonnier on les
accompagne dans la réalisation de leur
cv et également de l'ens lettres de
motivation et en plus de ça on leur
apporte un apport méthodologique sur la
limite de recherche de jobs d'été les
jeunes sont effectivement en pleine
recherche certains ont déjà commencé
bien en amont
maintenant il ya des on s'appuie aussi
sur le réseau information jeunesse et
notamment le cdj qui organise le
vendredi 13 mai une grande journée
dédiée aux jobs d'été d'ailleurs nous au
phare jeunesse nous pouvons les
accompagner à saint-ouen se vend le
vendredi 13 mai
[Musique]
avec laurence cousin vous êtes la
directrice de l'association yvelines
infos jeunes c'est un réseau national
ici on dans l'antenne des yvelines votre
objectif c'est donc donc on l'a dit
d'informer elle les jeunes ils peuvent
venir vous voir pour plein de sujets
pour être accompagnés mais là
aujourd'hui on va surtout s'intéresser
aux emplois saisonniers en ce moment la
haute saison en train de se préparer et
donc on vient vous voir peut-être pour
des jobs d'été est ce qu'on peut parler
un peu des tendances qu'est ce qui
attire plus les jeunes aujourd'hui
alors les tendances en fait c'est
souvent les mêmes depuis plusieurs
années qui dit jobs d'été dit aussi pas
forcément beaucoup de compétences donc
il faut que ça reste quand même des des
emplois accessible aux jeunes et donc
qui peut être accessible à cdc les
secteurs d'activité comme l'hôtellerie
restauration la restauration notamment
services à la personne l'animation
éventuellement voilà c'est vrai que
c'est des secteurs qui sont toujours
d'actualité et notamment dans la demande
et des jeunes puisqu'ils veulent des
métiers des jobs accessible donc ça
c'est la demande peut-être des
entreprises donc là où on peut trouver
le plus d'emplois et les jeunes c'est
vers ça qui se tourne des fois il vous
demande un petit peu après ça dépend
aussi de leur cv puisque nous en fait on
essaie de conseillers aussi les jeunes
en fonction vraiment individuellement en
fonction s'ils ont une formation
professionnelle des compétences
particulières bien entendu on peut
orienter aussi leurs recherches en
fonction de leur profil ce qui fait
qu'en plus pour les jobs d'été c'est
plutôt des périodes courtes donc il ya
ça aussi c'est ça ça peut être un
critère effectivement selon la
disponibilité une entreprise par exemple
qui a besoin de compétences
particulières si elle doit former le
jeune et qui reste que 15 jours
effectivement ce sera pas possible donc
il ya certes un job saisonnier qui
demande à deux voire trois mois minimum
de disponibilité donc ça c'est ce qu'il
faut vérifier déjà en amont cercle jaune
il faut qu'ils se posent les bonnes
questions on a un guide aussi inquiets
en version numérique et qui peuvent
aussi avoir en version papier qui leur
donnent tous ces conseils jeu moment
pour réfléchir un petit peu à quelles
sont leurs envies mais aussi voilà en
fonction de leur profil qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent quel job d'été peuvent-ils avoir
c'est tout ça qu'on peut leur apporter
ici donc ça c'est pour l'accompagnement
d'une manière générale tous les ans
quels sont les métiers un peu qu'ils
sont en tension qui vraiment sont dans
la demande on a parlé un peu de
l'hôtellerie restauration
quels sont les autres métiers peut-être
sont bien secs l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est vraiment très important
puisqu'elle c'est vrai que le co fut le
co vide est passée par là et il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui se sont
reconvertis donc il ya vraiment un
manque cruel
d'employés dans ce secteur l'animation
aussi à l'animation socioculturelle donc
encadrer des jeunes en colonie de
vacances
sur des centres de loisirs sans que ça
c'est c'est un vrai vivier mais ça peut
être la grande distribution la
logistique
il ya il ya quand même pas mal de
secteurs d'activité on a on a un gros
forum au niveau régional vingt portées
par le cdj il ya quatre mille offres de
jobs la cour en mai qu'ils soient qui
seront proposées aux jeunes dans
différents secteurs
justement les dettes on y reviendra un
peu tout à l'heure je vais rebondir ce
que vous aviez dit on parlait de
l'hôtellerie et surtout depuis depuis la
crise sanitaire parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de reconversion on a l'impression cette
année on a besoin d'entendre que les
entreprises peinent beaucoup à recruter
est ce que c'est une impression parce
que c'est vraiment le cas depuis la
crise sanitaire c'est vrai pas que pour
les jobs est effectivement c'est vrai
que je pense que les salariés ont pas
mal réfléchi se sont repositionnés ont
peut-être des exigences je pense
notamment au télétravail peut-être pas
pour les emplois saisonniers mais c'est
vrai qu effectivement ça pu évoluer et
du coup il faut que ça match et c'est
bon ça c'était déjà le cas avant mais
c'est peut-être encore plus plus évident
aujourd'hui nous on l'a dit ici yvelines
infos jeunes vous accompagner justement
les jeunes est ce que vous avez
peut-être des conseils à donner pour
bien trouver ou bien chercher son job
d'été son job saisonnier alors avant on
disait c'est vrai que ça a commencé
beaucoup plus tôt la la c'est un petit
peu aussi la différence par rapport à la
pandémie c'est à dire que là il est
encore temps on est en mai et les années
précédentes c'était plus tôt
février mars ont commencé les jeunes
commençaient déjà à chercher un job
d'été est là en fait justement peut-être
du fait de la pénurie et du besoin cruel
de
d'employés en fait effectivement là on
est dans la bonne période il est alors
y'a pas mal aussi maintenant de nouveaux
outils et de conseils qui peuvent
trouver en ligne chez les jeunes ils
sont aussi beaucoup en ligne donc il ya
des sur twitch et c'est donc des
supports qui leur permet d'avoir des
tutos des conseils en vidéo en pastilles
vidéo qui leur permettent voilà de de
pouvoir les consulter quand ils le
souhaitent et puis bah s'ils veulent un
contact direct il veut nous dans le
réseau information jeunesse mais c'est
vrai que ça reste très classique c'est
c'est un cv la démotivation alors après
ça peut être maintenant aussi en visio
compare les du télétravail ou de manière
dématérialisée de se présenter donc
c'est des conseils qu'on peut donner
aussi aux jeunes pour que voilà pour
adapter les bons
les bons réflexes en fait avec des
modalités qui sont pas toujours les
mêmes pas toujours les mêmes mais
finalement vous parler de la mode la
méthode les cv lettre de motivation ça
ça n'a pas changé reste alors la
classique est demandée par les
employeurs même pour un emploi
saisonnier tout à fait est-ce qu'il ya
par exemple une petite chose à faire en
plus au niveau de la méthode qui
pourrait faire la différence ce sont des
choses en fait de bon sens c'est-à-dire
comme l'ampleur souvent il a pas
beaucoup de temps donc comme mettre en
avant ses qualités souvent les gens ne
le voient pas forcément tout de suite au
delà de leur parcours scolaire on va
dire et puis surtout leur disponibilité
c'est un emploi il veut savoir va très
rapidement combien de temps déjà n'est
disponible si les mobiles ce genre de
choses donc ça sur un cv de lettres de
motivation et la lettre de motivation
bien sûr et complète le cv est donc
allée elle est surtout en lien avec le
poste visé c'est pas les fameuses pour
faire de lettres de motivation bateau on
va dire non l'idée c'est que c'est
vraiment en lien avec le poste qu'on a
choisi et qu'on puisse motiver ou en
fait sa demande on va refaire un point
aussi sur les data on en parlait tout à
l'heure juste avant je voudrais rebondir
ce que sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure la pénurie on parlait de on a du
mal à recruter aujourd'hui mais
finalement il y a toujours autant de
jeunes qui demandent pour les jobs d'été
ou est-ce que là aussi ça a baissé et
c'est pour ça qu'on aime pénurie et
quand may est encore temps il ya
toujours une demande parce qu on a aussi
fait main cette fameuse pandémie aussi
accentuer la précarité notamment des
étudiants on a quand même pas mal parler
dans les médias donc forcément tous les
ans il ya des jeunes qui ont besoin qui
s'est pas juste avoir envie c'est aussi
avoir besoin de travailler d'avoir un
emploi saisonnier pour financer ses
études différents projets individuels
donc il ya toujours autant de jeunes
voire plus de plus de jeunes qui ont
envie il ya aussi ces jeunes qui sont
très jeune c'est à dire qu'ils sont
mineurs alors même si légalement ils
peuvent travailler à partir de 16 ans on
sait que sur le terrain c'est toujours
plus compliqué mais qui peuvent quand
même chercher on les accompagne en ce
sens pour trouver un emploi saisonnier
pourquoi pas dans l'animation puisque le
bafa la formation d'animateurs on peut
la passer à partir de 17 ans donc nous
on fait des formations proposées
formation et puis on les informe sur les
sur les sessions de formation sur le sur
le territoire mais c'est vrai que ça
peut être une piste par exemple qu'on
peut leur proposez vous garder des
enfants chez des particuliers voilà on
s'adapte donc toujours autant de
demandes en tout cas chez les jeunes
tout à fait et du coup on va refaire un
point sur les dates quels sont les
événements à venir job dating ou alors
simplement trouver un job dit eh oui
alors il ya eu des choses en version
dématérialisée donc ça ça a lieu un
petit peu toute l'année il ya des
communes isère des vidéos aussi des
témoignages de jeunes qui donnent des
conseils c'est vrai que c'est bien aussi
que les jeunes dans les conseils aux
jeunes donc notamment sur le site du
csbj et puis je me retourne ce que j'ai
pas les dates en tête le grand événement
régional donc au cdj
porté par le cd gym qui sera à
saint-ouen cette année c'est le 13 mai
il ya donc envoyé plus de gdi 4000 c'est
plus de cinq mille offres qui seront
disponibles pour les jeunes donc là
vraiment c'est un rendez vous à ne pas
manquer avec son cv bien sûr et puis sur
les 78 dans notre réseau le 11 mai
prochain à porcheville donc une nouvelle
structure labellisée qui donc fait un
événement sur le mercredi après midi
pour les jeunes qui souhaitent trouver
un job d'été et puis on aura aussi
aubergenville ce sera le 18 mai sur
l'emploi en général et il y aura un
petit focus sur les jobs d'été et puis
là on n'a pas toutes les dates mais au
fil de l'eau de toute façon on
communique bien entendu sur notre site
internet sur nos réseaux sociaux et puis
il ya un site internet aussi régional
des jobs d'été hashtag job d'été qui
permet d'avoir sur toute l'île de france
tous les forums qui sont organisées sur
cette thématique là voilà là on peut se
renseigner on a le choix il ya en
attendant il faut être réactif et il ya
aucun problème si on peut être merci
beaucoup laurence cousin d'avoir été
avec nous je le rappelle un vous êtes à
la directrice donc de l'antenne
départementale des yvelines donc ils
dînent infos jeunes
[Musique]
trois listes de gauche sont proposés à
mantes la jolie pour l'élection
municipale partielle d'abord une
candidature rassemble la france
insoumise europe ecologie les verts et
le parti socialiste une équipe de gauche
mené par guillaume quévarec
objectif défendre un projet focaliser
sur trois priorités la jeunesse le
commerce et l'emploi puis le cadre de
vie et l'environnement alors tout de
suite on fait un audit sur les comptes
de la ville parce que malheureusement on
a un peu des doutes sur la sincérité des
comptes et l'état des finances ont fait
aussi un audit sur tous les programmes
immobiliers parce qu'on en a marre on
veut pas que cette ville ressemble à
quelque chose de d'archivés tony's et
donc on travaille dessus et après on met
le paquet sur l'éducation
donc on mettra en place dès la rentrée
de septembre des études dirigées dans
toutes les écoles et on entame un
programme de rénovation ambitieux en
termes de rénovation notamment
énergétiques des écoles et donner
davantage de moyens et dernier point
c'est le cadre de vie donc là dessus on
insiste beaucoup c'est à dire qu'on veut
développer les parties circulations
douces notamment vélo on veut développer
les espaces verts les lieux où les
habitants pourrait planter et le dernier
point pour nous qui est important c'est
de réassocier les habitants et les
associations à la prise de décision la
gauche ne sera pas totalement unie le
communiste marc jammet repart pour un
nouveau scrutin ce sera sa dixième
participation à une élection membres de
l'opposition municipale il défend
notamment un projet social avec une
limitation des opérations d'urbanisme et
un meilleur accès aux soins là sur les
projets d'urbanisme c'est dès le
lendemain de mon élection tant que maire
s'il est monté le vol c'est de suspendre
immédiatement toutes les opérations
d'urbanisme qui sont en cours et se dire
ben on n'est pas à six mois près et on
va engager alors il ya le référendum est
au milieu et à bord la conservation et
comment on fait pour concerter les gens
de les inviter à différentes choses et
de monter des projets interactifs nous
ce que nous proposons c'est de salariés
les médecins qui le veulent et d'aller
les chercher avec un médecin référant
salariés
qui s'occupera lui d'aller voir dans les
facs de médecine phase aller voir qu'il
allait proposer aux internes qui sortent
des facs de médecine horizons mais nous
on est d'accord pour vous salariés son
montage joli troisième candidature à
gauche sur l'échiquier politique la
liste de lutte ouvrière mené par thierry
gonot ouvrier à l'usiné renault de flins
il sera le porte parole pour défendre le
camp des travailleurs de mantes-la-jolie
une liste composée majoritairement
d'employés d'ouvriers mentez et mantaise
premier tour prévue le 15 mai prochain
pour renouveler le conseil municipal de
mantes la jolie
[Musique]
le premier tour des élections
législatives aura lieu le 12 juin 2022
face à ce scrutin à venir laurence
trochut ancienne présidente de sens
commun vient d'être investi par le parti
reconquête elle se présente dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
qui regroupe les villes de guyancourt
montigny le bretonneux et une partie de
versailles la présidente du mouvement
conservateur figure de l'opposition à la
pma et au mariage pour tous a annoncé sa
candidature sur les réseaux sociaux une
annonce suite à la commission nationale
d'investiture du parti le 28 avril
dernier
[Musique]
chaque année les lycéens de l'institut
notre dame de saint germain en laye se
mobilisent contre le cancer des enfants
ils soutiennent l'association imagine
fort margot créé en 2012 après le décès
de margaux élève à l'institut un live et
est organisé sur la chaîne youtube les
20 et 21 avril dernier li emd music show
2022 à cette occasion une cagnotte en
faveur de l'association a été lancé
objectif pour les 10 ans récolté dix
mille euros les deux live du concert
caritatif sont disponibles en
rediffusion sur youtube im/s 2022 et la
cagnotte est accessible via la
plateforme lots assauts déjà plus de
8000 euros ou pu être récolté l'argent
permettra de financer la recherche et du
matériel pour améliorer le quotidien des
enfants
[Musique]